you know what's the worst compliment you
and I could get as a salesperson we're
gonna talk about that today
I'm Patrick may there be a host of value
tainment in the world of sales we hear a
lot of different compliments lots of
different compliments people want to say
to reference a person being an
incredible sailor sales person yeah one
of the compliments could be it's
probably the famous one you've heard
before you know this person could sell
ice to an Eskimo right we've all heard
this one before let me give you some
modern once maybe you haven't heard
before some will have fun with you know
this person could sell newspaper to a
blind man
this person could sell underwear to a
nudist he could sell uh-uh he could sell
Cape to Superman he could sell a cage to
a lion he could sell Obamacare to
conservative he could sell you I'm gonna
stop I mean we hear all these different
lists of things that this person could
sell to all that person is saying is
they're trying to say hey you could sell
anything to everybody right and when you
really break down what that statement
really means here's what that statement
really means to me if I was to take them
to although it's a compliment if I was
to really take that interpretation so
our person doesn't sit there and say I
could sell anything to everybody when
you somebody said could sell anything to
everybody
that's not somebody I like to recruit to
my sales force I'll explain to you why
can you imagine if a person could sell
anything to everybody we put him in
front of a congregation of a Christian
Church he could convert anything anybody
into Christianity then you put him the
next day into a Muslim mosque he could
convert anybody into a Muslim you put
him the next day into an LDS Church you
can convert anybody into Mormonism next
thing Jehovah he can convert anything to
Joel but anybody into drove over 70
atheist agnostic because he's an
incredible salesperson right incredible
sales person in the world of business if
there's anything I could tell you that
as a salesperson you don't want to brag
about is you don't want to brag they can
sell anything to everybody you know
what's the one thing I don't like to see
on a resume here's what I don't like to
see on a resume if I see this I don't
this person if I see on the resume that
this person has sold 20 different
products my number is 5 generally if he
sold 5 different products over the last
20 years he's gonna sell another 5
products in the next 20 years if he sold
5 and 10 years he's gonna sell 5 in the
next 10 years this is a person that one
day they're selling cars and next day
they're selling insurance another day
they're selling real estate another day
they're selling pharmaceuticals sell
another day they're selling you know to
face another day they're selling coffee
this other day they're selling travel
another day they're selling this every
day there's something else they're great
sales people and they can convince you
but they're great salespeople I prefer a
true believer over a hundred salespeople
any day of the week let me explain you
the difference you see a true believer
could come in and he doesn't look like a
salesperson he's a regular guy a true
believer could come in and the different
questions that will be asked between a
true believer and a salesperson is this
a true believers gonna say tell me how
this product benefits our clients tell
me why our product is better than XYZ
tell me why our company stands for
something better than XYZ tell me what
makes us so special tell me what makes
us this oh and by the way how do we get
paid on these products again here's a
salesperson um how do we get paid on
these products oh by the way what is it
anyway what's the product you sell it
again what's it what's the progress all
it is I just need to know the basic
stuff I can go sell it to anybody
that's great I'll take the true believer
you know why because I can't replace the
true believers heart who believes in the
company who believes in a cause who
believes in a product you cannot you
cannot break a true believer anybody can
break a salesperson with a better
compensation plan anybody can break a
salesperson with a better you know any
all that others anybody can break a
sales person with that you can't break a
true believer a true believer
give me one true believer over a hundred
salespeople anybody the week
because I'm gonna pull my time until he
sells folks are gonna go sell another
product another project another product
another product all my hours I put went
to another product if I sit there and
develop a true believer
you better believe 5 10 15 20 years from
now the company is being ran by your
true believer the company is being ran
by a true believer because he believes
the company the product the cause what
you represent is what the true believer
represents now what will be an example
of both let me give you examples of both
what's a true believer what's the sales
person a sales person is as an athlete
somebody who comes in and after his
biggest contract he gets his best days
are behind him aka Andrew Bynum for
those of you guys that follow basketball
a true believer could be a guy like
Derek Fisher who's gonna fight for you
till the end he believes in your
organization he believes in your cause
everything about him is real in the
locker room he gives his best he may not
be your best player but he's a true
believer and you take Derek Fisher out
of the Lakers they don't have a lot of
championships cuz he was the only guy
that know how to speak to Kobe in the
locker room that's a true believer
hey salesperson could be a politician he
can get up in front of any audience
african-american white Hispanic Asian
Christian Catholic Muslim conservative
Republican liberal it doesn't matter he
can get in front of any audience because
he's a politician he can agree with your
points to get your book because he's a
politician and politicians typically
they take the high road you know they
kind of want to agree with everybody so
they don't make any enemies it's
actually a good power a position that
you have but it's not a true believer
you know what a true believer is a true
believer he gets up and he talks and she
speaks and 50% of the audience disagrees
a statesman gets up and says here's what
I believe in this is what you voted me
in for and fights for that thing that he
or she went in for that's a statesman a
statesman is a JFK a Reagan a Lincoln
that's a statesman politician I don't
need to give you any names
there are plenty of them on both sides
in politics politicians you know the
difference between a salesperson and a
true believer when it comes down to men
dating woman a salesperson is a man that
I'll say anything to get you into bed
with them and not I'm not timing getting
to bed to take a nap with them you know
what I'm talking about a true believer
is gonna tell you who he is what he
stands for is gonna ask you a lot of
questions about you what your family
stands for what you're all about what's
important to you because a true believer
has no desire of just getting you into
bed a true believer wants to build a
long-lasting relationship and family
with you and if those questions are
intimidating to you when you meet a man
like that or a woman like that you're
probably not in the true believer
department and if you find somebody like
that you better realize that person is
for real the more and more you meet with
them so I can go on and on and on give
you a lot of examples of you know what a
difference between a salesperson or true
believer is so my message to you would
be this here's what my message to you
would be one if you run a company you
run an organization make a list of your
true believers whoever your true
believers are of you who believe in you
who are aligned with you who believe in
your company who believe in a product to
believe in a cause and they're true
believers like when you talk to them you
really know they believe in what the
organization is all about
you better believe you got to put your
time into these folks because these are
the folks are gonna run the entire
company for you one day they're true
believers are not doing this for the
heck of it they automatically attract
money because people want to do business
with true believers and for yourself to
take inventory of yourself make a list
of things you've done in the last five
to ten years if you've done multiple
things in the last three to five years
you're not in the true believer
department I know most people don't to
hear that you're just not but if you sit
down and you make a list and you notice
your one in the last five years that's
good see if you can go 10 15 20 years
one message one company one cause one
movement one industry the longer you go
you're a true believer you know what
happens to a true believer would work
ethic where it comes from here not just
from here here and here when it comes
from here and here
you can attract a lot of true believers
you can attract a lot of salespeople
you'll attract every kind because when
people look at you in the eyes they see
true believer and people like following
true believers but you also know you can
have enemies and that's okay for every
one enemy or ten enemies or 50 enemies
or hundred enemies that you have a
handful of true believers will
compensate all overcome all all the
enemies you're gonna create you're gonna
be okay but history favours true
believers history doesn't favor
salespeople and politicians at favors
statesmen it favors true believers
that's my message to you my challenge to
you would be to go out there and look
for your true believers and put your
time into your true believers and to
work on identifying yourself as a true
believer and do one thing for five 10 15
20 years and look what happens you both
financially business-wise life wise
reputation in the community when your
name comes up they say what's he selling
now salesperson Oh him or he's been
selling one thing for the last 15 years
that's a true believer it's my message
of the week to you by the way if you
have any other one-liners that I didn't
cover I love to hear some of the funny
ones you got on the bottom and if you've
got some true believers on your team
that you work with be sure to share this
video with other true believers thanks
for watching and please be sure to
subscribe on about
you